hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy previously we
discussed the structure of a
glycerophospholipid and now I want to
talk about how we make them so here's a
glycerophospholipid with goods glycerol
backbone it's two acyl groups and it's
polar head group that includes a
phosphate group this is this whole thing
is often called a phospho a la so of
course this this whole portion is the
polar head group that we talked about
and mention when we talk about
glycerophospholipids so the question is
how are these things made there are four
steps the first thing that we do is we
form the glycerol backbone similar to
the what we did with the triglycerides
the second thing we do is we're going to
attach these fatty acyl groups via those
ester linkages alright these ester
linkages here and then we're going to do
is we're going to add the polar head
group via phospho phosphodiester
linkages right right there and right
there okay and before the final step is
we're going to alter the head group to
yield the final product and that's if
necessary this is an always necessary
step it may or may not be okay so it's
kind of get an overview of what that
might look like here the first thing
that we're going to do is form glycerol
3-phosphate which is what we saw earlier
with triglycerides this is basically
going to be our backbone right so this
first step here this first step here is
making our backbone and we get this
glycerol 3-phosphate from
dihydroxyacetone phosphate or glycerol
once we have glycerol 3-phosphate we
want to take that to form phosphatidic
how did we do that when we made
triglycerides well we just had a toll
transferases basically add acyl groups
and that's what happens here as well
yeah a gazel transferase is to make
those ester linkages to those acyl
groups then we have basta today that's
the common precursor once we have that
we want to add our polar head group
specifically by adding an alcohol of
some sort to this phosphate group that's
already here in phosphated 8 so we have
an alcohol group here so that's going to
be the addition of the polar head group
of course the phosphodiester bonds
going to be there and then we basically
have a plethora of phospholipids so
really it's only three steps that are
absolutely necessary but there are some
cases in which the the last step the
modification of that head group is
important to yield the final product the
final glycerophospholipid so something
might be changed slightly and we'll see
more details about that later in this
series one thing i do want to mention
even though that pretty much completes
the introduction is that we can also get
phosphatase from another molecule it
could come from this molecule
diacylglycerol if we have that a sub
woofer all we can do is basically all we
all we really would need to do is add a
phosphate group to replace this O H here
right to get fossa today and that's what
we do we just we add a kinase and we
basically invest some ATP here to give
us fossa today from Daiso glycerol and
these steps that follow can occur as
well to give us our glycerophospholipid
and modifications of course can give us
a final product if necessary so that's
sort of the overview of how to make a
glycerophospholipid I hope that video
was helpful thank you for watching
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and be sure to share
the video with anyone who you think
might find helpful thanks and happy
studying